la parole est à d'autres collègues
jacques grosperrin pour le groupe l'est
républicain et 2 minutes maximum
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre et l'éducation nationale et
j'aurais plaisir d'écouter la réponse de
monsieur mans dont les résultats du
baccalauréat bienne est rendue possible
et dans la tente d euros bien sûr ils
seront cette année encore excellent il
faut s'en réjouir mais cette apparence
excellence masquer une réalité fort
différentes
on va célébrer des résultats alors que
notre système éducatif décroche pisa les
évaluations internationales ne le montre
l'écho la république est en danger parce
que la politique de madame la ministre
et idéologique c'est un nivellement par
le bas et politique dans la mesure où
électoraliste dans la mesure où on
annonce aujourd'hui qu'il y aura des
créations de postes de 60000 enseignants
alors qu'on sait que là n'est pas le
problème et ça prend une structure elle
elle est également politique démagogique
en faisant croire que tout le monde peut
faire des études longues
vous avez annoncé la création de poste
on sait très bien où nous en sommes
vis-à vis cela vous avait dénaturé
l'esprit de jules ferry qui voulait
certes une instruction obligatoire
gratuite et laïque
mais il prenait avant tout les notions
d'effort de mérite et d'excellence qui
sont peut-être des mots tabous pour vous
le gouvernement socialiste
il fallait pousser les élèves quelle que
soit l'origine sociale atteint le haut
niveau possible avec comme modèle les
individus les plus brillants or vous
avez fait le contraire en supprimant les
classes de bilangue le grec et le latin
les notes le redoublement les bourses au
mérite
et puis enfin les internats d'excellence
que vous appelez maintenant les lycées
en tout cas de réussite quand
prendrez-vous des mesures courageuses
pour revenir à la vraie justice sociale
que prenait temps votre ministre jules
ferry qui était également socialiste
républicain merci merci la parole est à
monsieur thierry bordeaux en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur par une sorte de coïncidences
sens étymologique du terme
madame la ministre n'est pas là pour
vous répondre à cette question sur
l'excellence parce qu'elle est en train
de remettre les récompenses des élèves
de première et de terminale pour
l'excellence de leurs résultats
scolaires dans le cas du concours
général des lycées et des métiers ce qui
prouve que pour se dispenser d'une
séance au sénat
parce que là cette raison de saluer
l'excellence de nos résultats scolaires
il faut dire que depuis 2010 beaucoup
d'efforts ont été faits pour essayer de
conjurer conjuguer démocratisation du
système et exigences qualité d'abord les
travaux qui ont été faits pour assurer
sur tout le territoire une équité
territoriale avec des modalités
d'attribution vous en avez longuement
parlé ici de moyens beaucoup plus juste
qui soit soucieux de la réalité sociale
de chaque territoire qui permettent donc
aux équipes pédagogiques des territoires
les plus fragiles de disposer des moyens
de tirer vers le haut les jeunes enfants
scolarisés ensuite la réforme de
l'éducation prioritaire dont la carte
depuis 2015 est établi sur la base
d'objectifs et d'indicateurs que tout le
monde connaît adapté là encore à la
réalité sociale une école plus inclusive
qui permet aux plus fragiles d'avoir les
meilleures conditions de scolarité
notamment par l'augmentation des fonds
sociaux 70% par l'augmentation des
bourses sur critères sociaux 10% pour
créer des bourses pour les enfants
décrocheurs surtout la mise en place de
parcours d'excellence qui permettent de
conduire des jeunes de milieux de
modestes vers des poursuites d'études ou
une insertion professionnelle ambitieuse
et réussit enfin et surtout un
renforcement considérable de
l'encadrement à la fois les 60000 postes
qui permettent là encore de faire plus
d'efforts pour tirer l'ensemble des
enfants vers le haut et la formation des
faucons tueur pour que ces enseignants
disposent de tous les savoirs faire là
encore pour être le plus exigeant
possible bref si la politique n'est pas
aussi caricatural que ce que vous en
avez décrit bien au contraire elle vise
à accompagner la démocratisation
indispensable de notre système
d'enseignement scolaire par l'exigence
qualité sans laquelle celui ci perd sa
raison d'être
merci monsieur vendons je voudrais
simplement dire que nous ne voulons plus
d'une école uniforme de diplômes au
rabais de filières qu'ils n'ont plus le
nom que d'excellence et je conseillerais
je suis ravi que madame la ministre
belkacem soit au concours général
parce que des noms illustres comme comme
jaurès comme blum que chevènement
pompidou voir juppé pasteur etc ont eu
ce concours là et je la cite à revoir la
version 2005 le sujet 2005 du concours
général de la version latine qu'elle
n'aime peut-être pas le devoir des
gouvernants de cicéron qui disait aider
les élèves quel que soit pour favoriser
le résultat merci merci